hsl friend ogham the bindings are there
the faith god no no god damn it your
position in the hamper five-count if I
go no one
turns out
what's going on guys and girls it's
ghostrobo welcome to bioshock the
collection my favorite franchise redone
in 1080p up to 60 frames per second all
the games one package today taking a
look at BioShock Infinite the third and
most recent game in the franchise we've
entered Columbia the domain of Zachary
Comstock and where the adventures of
Booker Elizabeth and this weird world
will all take place there are looks at
Bioshock 1 and 2 already as well as
extended versions of these videos on my
channel this entire collection just
makes me super super happy they include
all the single player DLC and it's a
beautiful package seen Bioshock 1 in
rapture all redone for modern consoles
is crazy in this game in some ways is my
favorite the story here the mystery it
has such an awesome finish you have to
see this one through no matter who you
are and you can do that for yourself in
the game comes out the collection on
September 13th in north america and
September 16th internationally floating
city in the sky from the sea beneath to
the sky above interesting transition for
irrational and the team's behind
Bioshock I'm actually playing the game
right now at 2k they were kind of to fly
me up here not via one of these super
cool blimps but via an airplane to check
out the game and it's a super awesome
honor for me because like I said this is
my favorite video game franchise of all
time and sort of be able to play them in
full on gorgeous glory it's just awesome
so we are going to check out some of the
combat see some of the Vigors and give
you a little taste of what infinite has
to offer
so here we go with combat beginning with
a different weapon the skyhook here
which will eventually lead us into the
skies we transport around these
incredible vistas of Columbia and
execute our enemies here quite brutally
infinite gives you vigors instead of
plasmids but they still have oh my
goodness gracious did not remember that
part I fight all these games but it's
good to be back and in some ways it's
really really weird to be back they have
a creep factor to them that adds to the
charm in the weirdest of ways but we'll
take all of these guards and cops out
and proceed closer and closer to
monument island where our target
Elizabeth lies now there are some
notable improvements here in infinite
combat wise you gotta run button a
dedicated run button now you also have
more finely tuned shooting mechanics as
you'll see in a second here we can
possess this guy drop some coin on the
ground thank you audio logs are back in
the form of vaca phones vending machines
it retains all of the Bioshock spirit
but redone in a super interesting
Columbia 1900s style with a whole lot of
Americana and a whole lot of religious
overtones this guy here is a turret that
normally would not like us but we can
possess him our first vigor to do the
work for us we got salt this time
instead of Adam no will enter the fray
one of the coolest things about infinite
whereas bachik wanted to use many of the
same plasmids infinite has an entirely
new set of powers so vigor is a
different name but there's also totally
different functionality my favorite
being a bucking bronco a vigor that
ruptures the earth beneath your feet
almost like your own personal earthquake
and then undertow which is a later game
vigor that basically uses the sea as a
tentacle to knock your foes off ledges
or push them back from you shoot our way
through the game is a gorgeous game it
was at the top of the totem pole for
graphics back in the day when it came
out 2013 for Xbox 360 and ps3 and still
looks great now like it definitely has
that great mix of good strong visuals
and stellar art and aesthetic it's it's
a one-of-a-kind experience still
grabbing health kits I love the audio in
these games they're always always strong
and it's cool to hear some of the
underwater rapture sounds in a different
location again it's got the feel of
Bioshock but in a whole new world which
is what i really love Splore both stores
can load up on veggies because normally
we eat hotdogs and cake and candy bars
not the healthiest man this booker
dewitt continued through the streets of
columbia grab some salts grab some hell
it's getting hot what's going on
albanie a burning man mechanical rach
and he goes down not the kind of firemen
I'm familiar with but we will get our
second vigor Devils kiss here after
replenishing our stocks once
gosh that's brutal although I feel like
the the Colombians have it a bit easier
they said a drink the vigorous as
opposed to injecting themselves all
right the streets on fire that wasn't no
sample and we can swap back and forth
throwing fireballs if whoever comes our
way we can even make it a nice firework
show here which I really appreciate and
always found fun now let's swap the
possession take that over and you'll
begin to see the dynamic nature that is
the Bioshock combat and then combining
that with really cool intense and
well-written plot and characters is kind
of what distinguishes and separates
these games from the pack for me we get
a lot of really top to your titles these
days I think even in 2016 the Bioshock
trilogy holds up and excels in a way
that that many games just can't seem to
compete with and that's why I'm extra
happy have a chance to play them all we
gotta run away this guy is gonna shoot
us in the back and this little Piggly
Wiggly is not gonna protect us very well
at all excuse me sir please stop you're
shooting when I come in jumping forward
a little bit get to show off the sky hug
and some of the aerial exploration
that's included here can attach on and
traverse eventually we'll get to ride be
more roundabout skylines but we can do
skyline strikes which is an absolutely
incredible assassination move there and
it leaves them shocked and awed and not
waking up we've got machine guns here
adding to our arsenal and the weaponry
has a style that very much fits the time
period fits the city and then augmenting
that with something like Devils kiss it
is a pretty cool sight to behold
I've got a lot of very angry individuals
here urging us to use all of our
equipment and our shield early and off
we'll see if we can get whoa hello so
you can get sky high soon enough here
cuz it's pretty fun to fight while
you're floating above the ground we're
already floating so it's like a floating
inception boom sometimes you don't want
to possess the terrace east want to take
a mouth you can do that another level
layer of dudes as you can see like the
sugary has been refined to be much more
shooter s and we're quite able to really
wreck these guys looking back on
dropping down know where we go the line
for just a little bit more we're now
inside a very strange society of crow
obsessed creeps looking for their leader
and I believe he's right through these
double doors
is not a good way to go we're going to
try to prevent that from happening to
ourselves such a beautiful yet brutal
place all right we can create an
explosive trap so we'll do this as a
secondary use for the vicar's kind of a
cool tweet in traditional power formula
and that will burn the crazy crow leader
we say goodnight to him quite quickly
and acquire already our third power up
press to summon matters crows hold and
release to create a nest crap that the
crows now obey our command will carry us
forth against this next encounter not a
fun way to die being pecked to death by
a very dirty bird these and rapture
crows in Columbia that's for the foes
you really don't like at all but
hopefully you guys like the look of
BioShock Infinite also got looks at
Bioshock 1 and 2 as well as an extended
version of the videos on my channel
definitely check those out and make sure
to check out Bioshock the collection on
September the 13th North America
September's 16th internationally thanks
so much for watching guys girls hope
you're a fantastic day and enjoying
yourselves until next time drinks in my
chocolate watch out for those crows and
we'll see you all light
you